in August 2001 the press descended on
the town of Barris and admins in
southeast England the Mayor was going to
unveil the world's first Internet bench
here in the Abbey Gardens I'm not
sitting on the bench for a couple of
reasons one I can't get close-up static
while I'm sitting on it and two it looks
like quite a lot of the local bird life
has been perched above it recently
anyway internet bench sounds ridiculous
but you have to remember in 2001 there
were no smartphones Wi-Fi did
technically exist but it wasn't
widespread and mobile Internet was
limited to a few specially coated tiny
black and white sites which could be
accessed slowly and expensively on just
a few models of phone if you wanted an
internet connection in 2001 your
computer had to be plugged in somehow
you couldn't just expect to check your
email in a park and thus the Internet
bench a bench with sockets it could plug
your computer's modem into and dial-up
to be internet over a phone line which
is weird right because surely the
sensible thing to do even back then
would have been to have one internet
connection making a DSL line and then
share it like a regular corporate
network just plug in an Ethernet cable
please have a connection but no you had
to use a phone cable and your laptop
would have to dial a regular landline
phone number to connect to well who
launched a photos make it very clear who
you were supposed to connect to or least
it would if the mayor had realized which
way up stickers need to be on a laptop
this was all a publicity stunt for msn
the Microsoft Network and there are some
very nice quotes from Amazon staff in
the BBC article about it which were
probably pasted straight from the press
release in truth this wasn't really an
Internet bench it was a bench with a
couple of phone extensions run to it and
that was it for a three month trial
period you can dial up tear on the
internet account from here it didn't
take long before some local tech savvy
teenagers worked out there wasn't any
block on the number so you could call
from here the bench just had a few phone
sockets wired into the exchange
at Microsoft's expense so of course they
made a couple of international calls for
free and trying to get them to Bill
Gates they didn't manage it but they did
get a nice write-up in the local paper
and one of the most wonderful early
2000s post photos I have ever seen from
a technical standpoint this bench was a
disaster but MSN will probably happy
with it they've been happy with the
teenage hackers as well he got back on
three name in the paper again but
probably still happy with this video
even as I tell you it was a terrible
half-assed idea because what it did and
what it's still doing was get their name
and logo in front of an audience they
just want to be noticed it's one of the
dirty secrets of public relations if you
want to get the attention of the press
if you want your brand in front of the
world you don't have to actually make
something good or useful or sensible
that even works like you said it would
the truth is malleable you just have to
tell a story that resonates get the
press in to take some pictures and
figure they don't know enough about the
subject to ask technical questions and
then after you've got those column
inches or these days the retweets and
clicks you can basically abandon the
whole project the public are fine with
it it's a silly story that doesn't
matter the press are fine with it
they've got content and sold the adverts
around it and it doesn't matter if it
gets ripped apart later as long as it
doesn't kill or maim anyone then you've
got your free advertising and we've seen
this time after time after time heck
I've done it occasionally in the past
that's not even the same bench actually
it's the right location but it's pinspot
to help for a different one with a
couple of plaques on it and no phone
sockets but then the bench working was
never the point this wasn't about
connecting the town of various enjoyed
ones or blazing a trail into the future
it was about getting cheap advertising
and Here I am 20 years later still
giving them that because world's first
Internet bench still gets attention
Oh someone sat in it
you